Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Siste ist mein Name. Ich bin der Szenarstin auf dieser Station und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ist ja wichtig, dass jemand nach mir guckt.
Ja, okay. Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich gerne am Anfang ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rainer Kowermann.
Könnten Sie mir bitte Ihren Vorname und Nachname ansammeln?
Ja, da sind auch tatsächlich eine Menge Fallen drin.
Rainer schreibt man nämlich in meinem Fall mit R-E-I-N-E-R.
N-E-R.
Am Ende, ja.
Dann geht es der Familienname, ist Kowermann mit K-A-N-O-V-I-R-Mann.
I-V-Ita oder I-E-E-E-Mail?
Emil, okay.
Knoffermann.
Kowermann.
Okay.
Frau Kowermann.
Ja, ich bin ein Mann. Rainer ist ein Mann.
Okay, Herr Kowermann. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 52 Jahre und bin geboren am 20.09.69.
29.09.69.
69.
Okay.
So Herr Kowermann, was für Sie uns?
Ja, ich habe seit ein paar Tagen so unangenehme Schmerzen in der rechten Bade.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, das ist ein bisschen dick geworden.
Ich habe da immer so den Abdruck von den Strümpfen.
Und ja, das tut jetzt richtig weh beim Laufen insbesondere.
Und das zieht, also bis in die Kniekehle und ins Ganze, also ein ganz unter Schenkel.
Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, das muss ich doch mal vorführen.
Schicht zum Wade.
Sie haben Schmerzen.
Ist es Ihnen gefallen, Ihnen aufgefallen, das ist auch rot geworden, dicker geworden?
Ja, dicker ist es.
Nein, ich habe das festgestellt im Vergleich, weil eben die Socken so einschnüren.
Da habe ich dann gemerkt, dass das eine Bein dicker ist.
Eine Bein dicker ist.
Ist das Ihre Rechte oder?
Das rechte Bein ist das, was so weh tut.
Das ist okay, rechte Warte.
Strahlendische Masse.
Ja, das geht bis in die Kniekehle rein.
Der ganze Unterschenkel tut mir eigentlich inzwischen weh.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen bewegungsabhängig?
Na eigentlich sind die dauerhaft.
Also wenn ich das Bein hochlege, wird es ein bisschen besser.
Und wenn ich laufe, ja, dann werden die schon schlechter.
Aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass die nur beim Gehen da wären.
Sondern sie sind eigentlich immer da.
Okay.
Und Sie haben sich eben seit ein paar Tagen verschlechtert.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, ich bin vor vier Tagen von der langen Reise zurückgekommen.
Ich bin dienstlich viel unterwegs.
Und halt eine lange Flugreise.
Und das ist jetzt vor vier Tagen bin ich wieder angekommen.
Und am nächsten Tag fing das eigentlich an.
Und jetzt aber wird es wirklich seit heute Morgen oder der heute Nacht
fand ich eigentlich schon, dass ich nicht mehr gut schlafen konnte.
Und ich mein, durch den Jet-Ax schlafe ich sowieso schlecht.
Und dann kam jetzt noch die Schmerzen dazu.
Also, da hab ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt mich doch mal bei Ihnen melden.
Ja, ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese.
Wie lange dauerte Ihre Reise?
Oh, das war lange furchtbar.
11 Stunden unterwegs.
Mit Aufenthalt zwischendurch.
Aber mit Flugzeug.
Ja, in Flugzeug.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie irgendwas ausprobiert, um Ihre Schmerzen zu lernen,
außer Hochlage?
Eigentlich habe ich nichts, aber ich dachte, das geht von alleine wieder weg.
Aber ich habe jetzt keine Medikamente oder so genommen.
Keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Drücken?
Ja, wenn ich da drauf drücke, das mache ich einfach nicht.
Aber ich habe eigentlich immer so dieses Gefühl, dass das ein bisschen spannender der Unterschinkel.
Haben Sie an der Wase gedrückt? Auf der Wase gedrückt?
Nee, das hat auch von alleine wie getan.
Da braucht sich nichts zu drücken.
Haben Sie Topas Gefühl?
Nein, da habe ich noch alles.
Ich habe noch 10 Wackeln und ich kann nicht spüren,
aber ich habe keine Erfindungsstörung oder eine Muskelschwache.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen über Ihre Argäme und Gesundheitswahl.
Haben Sie Fibar?
Nein, ich finde es nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, aber das unregelmäßige Leben kommt schon mal ein bisschen durcheinander.
Sie wissen gerade, wenn man lange unterwegs ist.
Normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme.
Wie viel wie ganz Sie?
Was will ich denn im Augenblick?
Letzte Mal habe ich meine ich so 81 gewogen.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen oder abgenommen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich meine, das ist immer so stabil.
Wie sieht es aus mit Ihrem Verdauungssystem?
Haben Sie Verstopfung, Übelkeit, Tod, Brennen, Durchfall?
Am 1. habe ich Verstopfung, was aber auch an der unregelmäßigen Lebensweise nicht.
Auf Reisen ist dann passiert das schon mal.
Leite Sie am konditionalkrankungen?
Ich habe keine besonders gute Kondition.
Deswegen habe ich immer mal so Husten, wenn ich mich ein bisschen belaste.
Wenn ich meine Treppe hochlaufen muss oder weil der Fahrschul nicht funktioniert.
Wenn ich hinter jemandem herlaufe, dann merke ich das schon, dass ich ein bisschen luftnötig bin.
Dass ich so einen trockenen Husten habe.
Und sonst bekannt ist, eigentlich seit vielen Jahren, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Luft habe.
Seit vielen Jahren? Sie haben Bluthochstück.
Seit vielen Jahren, seit 15 Jahren.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie Luftnot und Husten haben. Seit wann haben Sie diese Wäsche?
Das habe ich schon lange. Ich bin halt nicht gut in Form, weil ich zu viel arbeite und zu wenig Sport mache.
Deswegen, wenn ich mich dann ein bisschen belaste, dann muss ich gleich Husten.
Ich nehme auch einen Medikament gegen diesen Husten. Das heißt Lord Tap.
Lord Tap.
Ist das Loratidin?
Ja, kann sein.
Sind Sie deswegen schon beim Arzt gewesen?
Ja, der Arzt hat mir das mal verschrieben.
Seitdem, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ich brauche das, dann nehme ich das.
Ja, wann war das?
Das ist schon lange her, bestimmt 4, 5 Jahre.
Aber das habe ich seit hier eigentlich immer, dass ich leicht mal so ein bisschen husten muss.
Haben Sie gerade Husten als Not?
Ja, so ein bisschen habe ich das schon. Ich denke, das kommt von der Klimaanlage im Flugzeug oder im Auto.
Ist das mehr als immer oder?
Mehr als normal.
Das ist so wie immer.
Okay.
Seit 5, 10 Jahren haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Mhm.
Haben Sie weitere Konkretkungen?
Ne, sonst bin ich Gott sei Dank ziemlich gesund.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente, da, Giggi?
Ja, ich nehme so ein regelmäßig jetzt Kandekor wegen des Blutrucks.
Das nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Könntest du mit der Gitarre holen? Kandekor?
Kandekor, ja.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, ich weiß das gar nicht genau. Ich meine, das sind 8 Milligramm.
8 Milligramm, 2 Mal abtun.
Mhm, genau.
Wie sieht es aus mit Ihrem Blutfeldweite?
Wissen Sie?
So viel, ich weiß in den Ordnung.
Da hat der Arzt noch nie etwas darüber gesagt.
Okay.
Herr Kollarmann, haben Sie Allergie?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas Allergie spiel.
Nein.
Unverzweiglichkeit gegen Lebensmarmus?
Ne, ne, ne, eigentlich kann ich alles essen.
Wie gesagt, manchmal führt das dann dazu, dass ich Verstopfung habe,
wenn ich so ungewöhnlich esse.
Aber normalerweise vertragen kann ich das schon.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft. Ja, klar.
Wenn man so viel im Ausland unterwegs ist,
da muss man immer sein,
der ganzen Impfung auf dem aktuellen Stand haben.
Wohin leisen Sie?
Ja, das kommt darauf an, wo ich halt gerade geschäftlich unterwegs bin.
Jetzt war ich in Kanada.
Manchmal bin ich in Mexiko.
Also je nachdem, wo ich gerade zu tun habe.
Reisen Sie auch in asiatische Ländern,
deswegen habe ich gebraucht.
Ach so, da war ich jetzt die letzten Jahre noch nicht.
Okay.
Ich benutze hier noch ein paar Informationen über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Errauchen Sie?
Ja, bei dem Stress geht es ohne Zigaretten nicht.
Ein Pilgchen am Tag brauche ich bestimmt, ja.
Ein Pilgchen am Tag.
Seit wann?
Ja, bestimmt.
30 Jahre schon.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ein Glas Rotwein trinke ich gerne mal.
Oder wenn man irgendwo eingeladen ist,
ein Schluck Wein oder ein Schluck Sekt oder so.
Ich würde nicht sagen täglich, aber schon nicht ganz selten.
Täglich.
Nein, nicht täglich, aber auch nicht nur hin und wieder,
sondern ziemlich regelmäßig, ich würde nicht sagen,
viermal in einer Woche oder so.
Viermal in der Woche, okay.
Ich hoffe, wenn man bitte nehmen,
sieht diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Hast du Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, das kommt mir nicht ans Haus.
Sie haben gesagt, dass viele Geschäftsreise machen.
Was sind Sie von mir?
Ich bin Geschäftsführer einer großen Firma.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Kinder sind alle gesund.
Gibt es wichtige Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Meine Mutter hat jetzt im Alter ein Diabetes bekommen,
ein Alterszucker, aber sonst sind alle gesund.
Leber in Ihrer Alter?
Ja, die sind hoch betagt, aber wir leben noch.
Die beiden leben noch?
Ja, die beiden leben noch.
Ihr Mutter hat Diabetes mehr als ihr Vater.
Du bist so gesund, der hat nichts bekommen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Gibt es irgendwas noch,
die Sie bemerkt haben,
oder nötigen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt,
Sie haben so viel gefragt.
Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht,
was ich Ihnen noch zusätzlich erzählen sollte.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Was machen Sie mit meinen Beinen?
Ja, ich vermute bei Ihnen
eine Gefäßverschluss.
Aber ich habe Sie noch nicht körperlich untersucht.
Ich werde Sie so als körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen
und ich werde eine untercharter Untersuchung veranlasen.
Dann kann ich sagen,
Ihre Diagnose.
Sie haben gesagt,
eine ultrachale Untersuchung machen Sie
und was müssen Sie noch machen?
Ich werde eine Ultrachaltersuchung veranlasen.
Ich werde Sie durchführen.
Ich werde Sie sehen, ob eine Verstöpfung
in Iran gefasst hat.
Und kann ich danach wieder nach Hause?
Ich müsste eigentlich dringend ins Büro.
Es ist so,
dass Sie bei uns unterbeobachtet bleiben müssen.
Aber ich werde Sie sehen,
dass Sie nicht mehr über die Untercharter
oder die Untercharter veranlasen.
Ich werde Sie sehen,
dass Sie wieder auf die Untercharter
und die Verstöpfung veranlasen.
Okay, gut.
Dann bis gleich.
Ja, dann werde ich Sie sehen.
Ich werde Sie sehen,
dass Sie nicht mehr über die Untercharter veranlasen.
dass Sie wieder auf die Untercharter veranlasen.
1 Minute!
Sie sind einmal, habe ich geschafft.
Äh, hat jemand noch Fragen aus dem Plenum?
Ich denke,
zwei Verhältnis.
Können Sie mir beschreiben,
Das hat sie nicht gefragt.
Und ich nicht verstehe, der Patientin hat gesagt, eine Medikamente, Lartap oder Welche.
Ja, Lortap. Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe das tatsächlich nicht nachgekauft.
Wie viel Milligramm?
50 Milligramm steht hier.
Da steht nur drin, dass es ein Antitossivum ist.
Deswegen bin ich davon auch.
Antitossiv, Antitossiv, Antire, Antire Medikamente.
Und ich habe, ich denke, eine Frage.
Wann wurde Damaz Diagnose gestatt?
Welche Diagnose?
Der Patient hat gesagt, vier bis fünf Jahre erst besuchen und...
Ach so, ja.
Welche Diagnose Damaz gestatt?
Das war wegen des Huskens.
Danach hatte sie gefragt.
Ich hatte gesagt, dass ich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen Husken habe
und dass das jetzt nicht besonders viel ist.
Das ist eher sowieso auch...
Hydrokodon steht jetzt hier.
Und nur die finanziellen Diagnose müssen wir gestellt.
Haben sie Herzrasen, Stolpen?
Stimmt, das hat sie nicht gefragt.
Sie hat noch eine Sache nicht gefragt.
Die wäre tatsächlich ziemlich zielfühlt gewesen.
Sie hat nicht davor Operationen gefragt.
Ja, davor Operationen.
Sie hat nur nach Krankheiten gefragt, aber so chronischen Krankheiten,
aber nicht nach Vor-OPs.
Und dann hätte ich nämlich gesagt,
dass ich am anderen Bein eine Krampfader-Operation hatte.
Ja.
Und noch eine Frage habe ich.
Das ist nicht für mich so klar.
So seitige Konditionen, ihre so seitige Konditionen,
Sie haben schon gesagt, schon lange her haben sie Hüsten und Luftnord.
Ich möchte so seitige Beschwerde...
Wie aktuell bist du denn?
Aktuell beschwerde ich.
Wie viel Stock könnten Sie einsteigen, zum Beispiel?
Wo er war, wie viel jetzt?
Also, das ist jetzt nicht schlechter als sonst.
Das ist jetzt nicht schlechter als sonst.
Er hat so ein bisschen Hüsten und er hat bei Belastung,
hat er schon lange so ein bisschen Atemnot,
aber das ist jetzt nicht deutlich verschlechtert.
Okay, danke.
Ist das gut?
Okay.
Haben Sie ein endiger Gefühl in der Brust?
Das tun wir jetzt langsam.
Ja, stimmt, das hätte man noch fragen können.
Gut, halt aber nicht.
Gut, sollen wir schon zum Arztgespräch kommen?
Ja, gut.
Ja, so wie wir die Operation jetzt fragen, oder?
Sie können ja so tun, als hätten Sie gefragt.
Ja, und Sie wissen das jetzt,
dass deine Varizenoperation auf der anderen Seite hat, ne?
Okay.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke.
Herr Hofermann ist ein 52-jähriger Patient,
der sie bei uns wegen vor drei Tagen auftreten.
Also Schmerzen in der rechten Wade.
Schmerzen in der rechten Wade.
Schmerzen sind in den Knien.
Ja, in den Knien.
Und Sie, die Schmerzen,
die Hochlage Schmerzen bringen etwas Verbesserung.
Und die Patient hat berichtet,
dass sie bei der Bewegung schlechter werden.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat auch schon hinzugefügt,
dass sie seit drei Tagen wegen der Schmerzen nicht schlafen kann.
Sie hat dagegen...
Ja, ja, ist da immer ein Mann.
Ich habe gegen keine Medikamente angerufen.
Die Fragen,
die Säste, die Paräste, die Muskelschwache und Laumung wurden verneint.
Ja.
Die vegetative Anamnese hat keine Auffälligkeit.
Als für die Krankenung hat der Patient seit fünfzehn Jahren
Arteriellehypertone,
sie erneut die Gegend kandikar acht Milligramm Weimar Amtak.
Er hat erwähnt,
dass sie das für vier bis fünf Jahre,
für vier bis fünf Jahre
die Höchstdünste und die Düstene zu haben.
Er nimmt die Gegend für fünf bis sechs Milligramm Tablet.
Sie hat die Diagnose gefrackt,
aber der Patient hat nicht...
Er hat es nicht gefrackt.
Sie haben gesagt,
vor fünf Jahren, seit fünf Jahren.
Das dauert ja eigentlich noch ein.
Keine Allergen, keine Unfallträglichkeiten
sind bei den Patienten bekannt.
Er ist vorstellig geimpft.
Er hat sich nicht verabredet,
dass man 30 Packungen Gerätikonsum.
Er trinkt ein Glas Wein viermal in der Woche.
Der Patient ist Geschäftsführer vom Beruf.
Er ist verheiratet und trinkt.
Er hat sich nicht verabredet.
Ja, ich habe ihn nicht nachgefragt, aber er hat ja alte Seite getragen, deswegen muss er
zu Hause sein.
Okay, gut, ja.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist ein dynamistischer Angaben für die beiden Patienten, Tifa Tee,
Teefenentrumgose, dafür Sprachen, Zigarettenkonsum, Langerise, Elfstunden Lange, Fluxox Reise.
Und Reise, hm?
Und von den Symptomen, was bricht da dafür?
Und dann sieht man Bewegungsbedingte, Beinschmasten, verdickte Bein und der Patient hat gesagt,
dass Hochlagerung ringsverbesserung, das weiß auf, das weiß auf auch Tifa Teechen.
Ja, was wäre Differenzialdiagnose möglich?
Differenzialdiagnose kommen erisipal, erisipal auch Piafeka in Wetzaracht.
Noch irgendwas?
Natürlich.
Denken Sie mal, dass das in die Kniekehle strahlt.
Muskelris?
Ich denke gerade an etwas anderes, das ist hier als Differenzialdiagnose noch aufgeführt.
Und es ist tatsächlich in der Praxis nicht so selten, dass Leute vom Hausarzt geschickt werden zum Gefäßdirogen
und dann ist es eine Bakersiste.
Ja, also gerade wenn die Kniekehle, Vendaneschwellung ist, denken viele erstmal, das ist eine Trombose,
aber es ist dann oft tatsächlich nur eine Belkatsiste.
Ja, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Als diagnostisch würde ich so als der Patient körperliche Untersuchung,
ja, so als ich überprüfe die Vital-Sachnen, weil in diesem Fall es gibt auch einen Gepard von Pulmonaremboli,
aber der Patient hat keine Symptome, aber ich muss es nicht zu sichern.
Zur Sicherheit wollen Sie gucken.
Und wo nach gucken Sie sonst bei der körperlichen Untersuchung auf alle Fälle?
Wo legen Sie den Schwerpunkt drauf?
Wo nach suchen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Im Bein oder General-Fragensie?
Im Bein.
Ja, am Bein.
Am Bein, um die Hormonsachnen, Papäär-Sachnen, bei dem Dorseflexion, ob der Patient Wadenschmerz hat,
ich würde diese Sachnen überprüfen.
Genau, die Klassik haben.
Und was machen Sie aparativ?
Akkoretiv, Doppler-Ultrasoneografie.
Ja, genau.
Und CT-Angiografie.
Ja, eigentlich nur, wenn der Doppler nicht aussagefähig ist.
Ja, ja.
Und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labortechnisch, ja, um eine Entsundung erisipal auszuschließen würde ich
eine Sere-PBSG- und eine Impulus-Bitlocustos-Bächtemann.
Und ja, Dedimar...
Auf alle Fälle, ne?
Ja, das ist eigentlich die Trombose, wäre dann gesichert.
Wobei, beim Erisipel, was würden Sie da sehen, wenn Sie das Bein angucken, vom Aspekt?
Geschwollene Gerotete.
Ja, die Ruhigung mit der Inflammation ist ein ganz eindeutiges Zeichen, ne?
Ja, wenn sich das Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigt, dass der eine TVT hat, im Unterstänkel,
was wäre denn dann die Therapieoption?
Ja, die Therapieoption würde wäre Antikogilasioterapie mit...
Niedrigmolekulare Hyparin.
Mit Niedrigmolekulare Hyparin, ja, okay.
Mit Niedrigmolekulare Hyparin und Inviteram Farlov mit Kumadin.
Das ist auch eine neue Antikogilasioterapie, wie Apixaban Daligatran.
Genau.
Die Therapie ist in diesem Fall indistisch.
Aber wie lange?
3 Monate lang. 6 Monate lang, oder?
Ja, genau.
Gut, was machen Sie noch mit den Patienten?
Was kriegt der noch außer seiner Anticoagulation?
Ja, Lebensstilintervention ist in diesem Fall...
Ich würde dann Patientin empfohlen.
Oder Strumpf...
Ja, den mein ich eigentlich erst mal, ne?
Genau.
Also, der geht nicht aus dem Haus ohne Kompressionsbandage.
Und kriegt einen Strumpf verordnet, ne?
Ja.
Wie lange ist der Strumpf?
Ich denke davon, ab wo der Strumpf ist.
Ja, der strahlt ja ein bisschen kniesach, der also...
Ja, ober hat, ja, ober hat der kniebes...
Also, leist den Strumpf, ne?
Ja, leist den Strumpf.
Das ist A bis G.
Ja, gut.
Und welche Kompressionsklasse wissen Sie das?
Kompressionsklasse?
Es gibt verschiedene Stärke von Strumpfen.
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Klasse 2, klasse 2, ja, ist egal.
Gut.
Ja, muss der stationär aufgenommen werden?
Der Patient hat stationär aufgenommen und warten.
Der Patient hat keine lebensbedrohliche Zeichnung, würde ich sagen, aber...
Ja, also, wenn er nach Hause geht, was muss man ihm sagen?
Was muss man ihm sagen, wenn er nach Hause geht?
Er muss natürlich ein Kompressionsstrumpf haben,
er muss das Makoma haben,
muss aufgeklärt sein, dass er das weiter spritzen muss,
das überlappend irgendwann die...
Er quatscht andersrum, er kriegt erstmal Heparin
und dass er nachher überlappend Makoma bekommt
und dass er seinen Strumpf regelmäßig tragen muss.
Worauf muss er noch achten?
Es besteht eine Molligefahrt, deswegen...
Ja, das ist der Punkt, genau.
Er soll etwas machen?
Er soll etwas heilen, okay.
Aber, was ist denn, wenn er merkt,
dass er Husten kriegt oder dass er Husten mehr wird?
Ja, er muss sofort in Hustenmutterorten...
Also, dann muss er sofort wiederkommen, notfallmäßig, ja?
Sobald er Luftnot kriegt und sich das verschlechtert,
der Husten, er hat ja vorher geschildert,
den habe ich immer so, den Husten, der ist nicht schon,
aber sobald er da, wie ich das merke,
muss er sofort wiederkommen und notfallmäßig eben auch.
Genau.
Gut, ja.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was Sie mit Herrn Kovaman machen
und was die Untersuchung ergibt, ja?
Okay, okay.
Dankeschön.
Wer hat noch etwas dazu zu sagen
zu diesem Patientin oder zu unserem Gespräch?